la dame noire organise son 17e tournoi
d'échec une heure chaos du 18 au 20 mai
on parle bien sûr des échecs et de
champion du club organisateur de
Montigny-le-Bretonneux sont autour de
cette table bonsoir à James Bonson
bonsoir adhérents pour la dame noire à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux Damien rivière
également tout jeune adhérent également
à la dame noire Montigny le Bretonneux
comment se déroule c'est parti tournoi
d'échec une heure chaos comment ça se
déroule tout à fait normalement mais que
des pendules bien sûr et on a qu'une
seule heure pour jouer c'est à dire
qu'on peut aussi perdre autant ça veut
dire qu'on ça modifie profondément la
façon de jouer aussi d'avoir ce coup
près de l'horaire comme on vous
appréhendez ça chacun par exemple cette
limite de l'heure il faut jouer
lentement au début savoir accélérer je
viendra à partir du 25e 30e coup il faut
vraiment pouvoir
jouer beaucoup plus vite c'est une
formule que toi tu apprécies
au début les jeunes ils jouent ont
tendance à jouer plus vite et moi du
coup ça me gêne pas trop de jouer
undercoeur parce que ce qu'il faut aussi
préciser sur ce genre de tournoi c'est
que tous les âges toutes les tous les
sexes se rencontrent il y a pas de
catégories il y a des prix par catégorie
après mais on joue tous ensemble
comment ça se passe quand vous vous
rencontrez d'ailleurs peut-être faire
une parenthèse quand il y a le choc des
générations sur une partie il y a une
vraie différence dans la façon de jouer
oui quand même au niveau du jeu ils ont
les personnes plus âgées dans cette plus
passif plutôt dans le jeu ils sont ils
attendent voilà vous attendez
nous avons plus de métiers ce qui nous
permet de mieux jouer les finales donc
d'arriver de façon plus décontractée
justement dans les derniers le tournoi
se déroule du 18 au 20 mai les
indications vont s'afficher pour ceux
qui souhaiteraient tout simplement il y
assister voir ces différentes parties
qui vont se tenir sur trois jours 17e
édition du tournoi aujourd'hui quel est
le niveau par ce tournoi
il y a toujours des très forts joueurs
qui viennent qui s'inscrivent en général
le dernier moment pour ramasser les prix
et nous nous venons pour rencontrer des
très fort joueur et non pour ramasser
les prix comment se débrouiller le club
justement de Montigny on parlera de vos
performances à chacun mais le club en
général
c'est le troisième club des Yvelines par
la taille et en général par les
performances on a envoyé trois jeunes au
championnat de France par exemple cette
année
on se débrouille en National 3 4 et 5 on
est encore une équipe qualifiant coupe
le Baker en coupe 2000 et une en finale
de caterium tour et puis il y a nos
jeunes qui se débrouille pas mal on a
deux équipes de jeunes Damien peut en
parler je pense en National de jeunes
donc on rencontre des des autres clubs
donc du Nord de la France pour la
nationale de jeunes
toi tu joues dans ces catégories là
ce qui explique que tu ne seras pas
présent pour le tournoi là
pour cette pour cette compétition
nationale petite frustration de pas
jouer sur le tournoi oui peut-être un
peu mais bon j'aime bien aussi pour la
vaisselle de jeunes parce qu'on joue
pour le club pour le maintien en fait
quels sont vos classement respectifs à
chacun
disons que je suis en ce qu'on ce que
l'on appelait jeudi c'est la troisième
catégorie
bon ce lien entre 1600 et 1800 mais plus
près du 1800
et 1700
viendrait sur le plateau mais aussi
préciser que c'était un jeune espoir du
club prometteur c'est le cas oui il a
bah par exemple il a été le premier nom
qualifié dans sa catégorie au
championnat de France
il y avait 9 qualifiés en Île-de-France
qui est une très bonne région c'est
beaucoup plus difficile de se qualifier
dans la région que dans Limousin ou
l'Auvergne et sans dire du mal de ces
régions et il a fini 10e donc premier
non qualifié depuis quand tu choisis aux
échecs
ou ton papa qui attend au loge
en fait c'était des amis de mes parents
qui ont proposé que je vous échecs comme
j'aimais bien les mathématiques et je
suis allé après au club et ça m'a tout
de suite plus joindre le club justement
c'est à peu près la moitié la moitié du
club nous satisfaire vous devez être
content de voir qu'elle me relève et que
la discipline est plutôt appréciée
depuis le début on est environ
moitié de jeune moitié d'adultes ça fait
une cinquantaine vous jouez en catégorie
Vétérans oui je trouve que c'est aussi
vétérans mais il y a pas de prix pour
les vétérans à ce tournoi oui objectif
un tournoi ma première participation il
y a quatre ans et j'aimerais bien à
nouveau être sur le podium
je suis fatigué vous savez un petit peu
les adversaires que vous allez
rencontrer
les échecs de façon générale
les effets si vous voulez le
s'il y a un nombre n de joueurs à la
première onde le numéro 1 rencontre le
niveau enfin celui qui a une qui est le
N sur deux plus un
le numéro 2 rencontre la sur deux plus
deux et ainsi de suite pourquoi il faut
être très fort en mathématiques ne
serait-ce que pour comprendre comment ça
se déroule pour choisir les adversaires
toi tu n'as pas d'objectif sur ce
tournoi là tu es un objectif sur la
saison en revanche puisque tu disais
toujours nationale l'objectif c'est quoi
pour toi bah là j'ai au niveau du
classement j'aimerais bien déjà dépasser
les 1700 et puis oui pour la nationale
de jeunes on a sur le maintien si on
gagne on peut espérer être obligé déjà
faudrait gagner ce match donc ce sera un
gros weekend de charger pour ce club de
la dame noire à Montigny-le-Bretonneux
et il y aura d'autres projets par la
suite aussi
la saison prochaine donc nous avons déjà
nous organisons un tournoi international
de maître
ça doit être du 19 au 27 saint on a
fermé il y a 10 joueurs du 19 au 27
octobre dans une salle définir sur la
ville nouvelle
il y a déjà un azéri un roumain et un
Bulgare enfin je parle de gemmes de
grand-mère qui sont inscrits il y a un
jeune du département qui viendra aussi
qui s'appelle
cambrat Yannick cambrat qui est en
pleine progression qui était formé à
Villepreux
les autres joueurs y aura vraiment un
Italien un espagnol on est en train de
les inviter il a fait des aussi un vide
des joueurs et il y en a que 6 ou 7 des
tournages de ce type parent qui
permettent à des jeunes d'obtenir leur
première norme
et puis surtout nous organisons le
championnat cette année
jeunes il y aura 250 jeunes au stade
Pierre de Coubertin à Montigny ça doit
être le 10 novembre de mémoire à
dimanche c'est quelque chose à vraiment
aller voir l'occasion bien sûr on en
reparler puisque ce sera à l'occasion
des 25 ans du club nous en parlerons
forcément dans une prochaine édition du
7 8 on redonne déjà les dates de ce
prochain tournoi 1h CAO 18 au 20 mai une
fois de plus les informations qui
s'affichent pour y participer peut-être
à la dernière minute ou alors si vous
souhaitez tout simplement voir ces
champions jouer merci à tous les deux et
puis bonne chance pour la suite de vos
compétitions respectives